(both speaking indistinctly)
All right, Drew. Well, we talked about our singles
are raring to go after lockdown,
you know you are.
Well, now the New York Post reports
that they're already at it
and the hottest new club is the vaccine line.
People are finding dates while they're getting their shots.
The article reported
that one woman said her 70 year old mom
got asked out in the vaccine line,
get it girl.
Apparently there's a lot of flirting going on.
And now dating sites like Coffee Meets Bagel.
Have you heard of that one?
Yeah, they actually let you advertise your vac status
to attract a mate
which I think more dating apps are gonna do, right?
I think, we've all been locked down forever.
It's been 14 months since you've been touched
by somebody else.
You look at them, "You're safe, you're good.
It's on. Let's go"
(Drew laughs)
Well, let everybody bloom.
Yes, please.
Well, people are frisky for Pfizer
but they're also getting frisky with their home decor
and we've been cooped up so long.
It inspired a playful new design trend.
Vogue, says that this year it's all about the squiggle,
the wobble and the blog.
Check out these photos.
I find this so joyous.
I love the cuts and angles.
Designers are working more with fun surprising shapes
and people are leaning away
from the clean, predictable lines of mid-century modern
and looking for something more whimsical and playful.
I mean, I love a blob Ross,
do you love a blob Ross Ross?
I do Drew.
I think square is so square, right?
And it is fun to incorporate
just a little bit of whimsy, have some fun.
During a lockdown,
I actually redid the tiles
in my back splash and Palm Springs.
And look, that's the back splash in my kitchen.
And so it's just a little sub space,
but with something whimsical
totally changed the vibe, right?
Massively transformational.
You don't have to do a whole room over
or go crazy or spend a lot of money or be overwhelmed by it.
Just start with an object.
And then you might use that as the inspiration in itself.
And so I just love this story
and I love everything design your turn.
Yeah. - Have some fun people,
go nuts.
Oh, and drew, I have a good story for you.
You know your favorite cozy boot
just got climate friendly.
Popsugar reports that UGG
has released their plant power collection
of carbon neutral line of shoes
made with renewable plant materials.
They've got fluff sugar sole sandal.
It's made with renewable sugar cane
and the Neumel natural boot made of hemp.
And both of these...
Like the crops actually absorb CO2 from the air.
And there's another one,
the Hevia rubber boot is made of latex
that's harvested from live rubber trees.
Really?
That's true.
I have to say my daughter, Olive
has like the red version of these.
These are a little shorter.
It's almost like if it got a haircut.
Yes.
And these are super on trend.
I mean, can you not see like a Kendall Jenner
throwing one of these
and it becomes the hottest shoe on the planet?
In a heart beat. And you know,
they have this huge UGG store
in Manhattan on fifth Avenue.
Yes.
And we talked about how we wanted to go in.
I did.
(Drew shouting)
I did. And I went in and I...
You think you know UGGs, right?
But yet don't.
They are changing the game.
And I kind of wanted everything.
This is a little big bird for me, the color.
It's muppety.
But yes, I'm not convinced that's a bad thing though.
Don't you want to wear that around the house like a Sunday?
Again, one girl wears it
and it's going to be the hottest trend.
And I really do love their new straps with their branding.
I will say this.
Thank you UGG.
Thank you so much
for showing what can be done environmentally.
I'm so grateful.
Any company out there that's doing it different
and realizing a new way
is how we're gonna make it here on this planet.
So my gratitude to you.
Check this story out
because I think it's been a really feel good show.
There is a national mom and pop business owners day
and we have a great story from the Denim Springs, Louisiana
that shows why mom and pop shops
are so important to our communities.
Sunny Skyz reports that the owners
of Poppy's fajita factory have devised an easy way
for customers to help the hungry.
And when you pay for your meal
or you can buy a meal for someone else.
At the very same time,
a coupon is printed out
and tacked to the wall and anyone who needs it
can take one of those coupons as a voucher
and get a hot meal.
It's beautiful, simple,
easy way to take care of the people around you.
And I hope this practice spreads far and wide
saving the planet and saving each other.
Absolutely. Get your fajita
and give someone a free jita.
That's right, exactly right, Rossi.
I think we have really good news today.
We did.
(upbeat music)